hi I'm Eric Foss in deadpool two
released a new berry reference a look at
the upcoming sequel in June 2018 and as
a true Deadpool teaser this is like two
minutes of trolling and literally ten
seconds of actual film footage which I
don't mind at all 95 percent rolling
thumbs up pretty much all of Deadpool
and I wouldn't have it any other way in
fact I wouldn't be surprised if the
Deadpool team cut this teaser
specifically for YouTube nut jobs like
me to over explain it so screw it I'll
be your sheep let's break down every
last one of these details face it you
don't want to feel like you've missed
anything do you we are all sheep let's
get started the opening minute and a
half is a parody of Bob Ross's long
beloved TV show the joy of painting
which actually enjoyed a kind of second
life online in recent years people with
ASMR are apparently crazy for his soft
voice and happy little brush strokes so
people have organized a database of all
403 of his paintings others have been
recreating each one wet-on-wet is a
painting term for a watercolor on a wet
surface that through Deadpool it of
course has a dirty connotation he
doubles down on this by describing the
powder snow like cocaine and the way he
talks about the paintbrush whack that
off you look good yeah all of the colors
listen to the bottom of the screen are
references the Clockwork Orange is a
reference to Stanley Kubrick's A
Clockwork Orange girls of indigo for the
folk rock duo Indigo Girls Soylent Green
for the movie Soylent Green a dystopian
future movie where they convert people
into food men in black seems to be
referencing men in black but I'm curious
why they spelled men in that way maybe
it's referencing the men in deodorant
brand or maybe it's the metal band minun
who released a song called planet black
in 2010 box-office gold is a nod to the
huge box office money of the first
Deadpool movie Doc Brown a little-known
cowboy scientist from Back to the Future
Part 3 Meridian pink for the Molly
Ringwald John Hughes 80s movie silver
licious is one of the issues of the
Pinkalicious kids book series yellow
snow a delicious salty snow that they
all tell you not to eat for some reason
red dits
red it's for those who neither post nor
lurk reddit is a site where people yell
about video games and Betty White
America's grandma and one of the Golden
Girls Wade Wilson's obsession with Bea
Arthur from the Golden Girls has come up
in the comics in the first movie the
golden girl reference comes up later
then after a Bob Ross fool gets scared
by what looks like his own crude
Deadpool logo the trailer smash cuts
into 10 seconds of actual film footage
so
let's take a look
okay this ten seconds is packed with
details there's some gunfire action
followed by an explosion in this factory
looking place now I'm not sure where
this is maybe some new Weapon X type
facility but notice how several these
people are dressed in bright yellow
maybe some dark blue mixed in there too
judging from negasonic classic x-men
yellow jumpsuit later these are probably
other x-men so I'm thinking this could
be part of some x-men mission that
Deadpool either helps with or just
sabotage us in some fun way we get a
quick shot of Vanessa jumping up and
giving way to kiss followed by this
great shot of dopinder the taxi driver
from the first film notice how
Deadpool's arm is wrapped in duct tape
here maybe he has a wound that's just
healing too slowly or maybe his arm got
severed completely and he couldn't wait
for it to regenerate so he just taped it
back together then there's negasonic
teenage warhead flipping us off with a
new hairdo
remember Deadpool kalter Sinead O'Connor
and alien 3 Ripley in the first movie so
I'm wondering what I'll call her now
maybe post twilight Kristen Stewart her
x-men jumpsuit looks different here for
one the circlex logo has been added to
her chest but also the color looks so
much more saturated here compared to the
first movie it looks like Deadpool two
might embrace even brighter color
grading to make this look more like the
comics also that truck behind her is the
same one that smashes into a building
later and it has these Weapon X looking
crates on it kind of like the one
Francis was sitting on in the beginning
of the first movie so this shot could be
part of a sequence where like she and
ippo work together to stop this runaway
truck and save some Weapon X patients
there's also this range shot of Wade
superhero landing and ramming into a car
like the juggernaut with the impact
smashing a guy in a passenger seat then
we get this very interesting shot of
Julia Denison's character that's a kid
from hunt for the wilderness film by
thor ragnarok director Taika Waititi it
looks like he's torching this place
notice how his hands are glowing now
there are several characters in the
x-men universe with fire abilities
there's pyro whom we saw in X 2 and X
been the last fan there are other mutant
fire starters like Wiccan and Sun fire
or it could be plants a new character
we'll see but what is this place exactly
you know the banners behind him prepare
yourself the Indus near with a menacing
figure with an X logo on the chest your
blood purity humanity infinity yeah so
my guess this is some doomsday cult run
by humans who fear mutants will bring
about the end of the world but a look of
a Denison's character is doing his best
to confirm that fear in a similar fiery
location is Domino played by ZZ beats in
the
my stamina is a mutant from the x-force
she's an expert sharpshooter and she can
alter the probability of situations she
is also in the past been a partner and
love interest to cable next we see blind
Al and weasel arming up this great shot
of Deadpool rising out of a casket for a
surprise hit at a Funeral which kind of
reminds me of Terminator 3 when they
retrieve all the weapons and Sarah
Connors casket there's a quick shot of
Deadpool tossing a chainsaw behind him
while hundred dollar bills rained down
I'm not sure what's going on here but
I'm probably gonna love it and then this
quick shot of chimichangas Wade's
favorite food warming in a toaster oven
okay then we return to Bob Ross pool
with this Norman Rockwell esque family
painting is actually ran in a recent
issue of Good Housekeeping with Deadpool
on the cover including Josh Brolin's
cable and a portrait of Stanley on the
wall and then these joke credits roll
with a ton more references the executive
paint deucer is Ross Bob art a play on
Bob Ross art the lead singers Jerrica
Benton which is the name of the lead
singer of Jim the chief engineer is
Geordi LaForge levar Burton's character
from Star Trek The Next Generation video
editing by Blanche Devereaux that's room
a clan Anne's character in Golden Girls
audio by Teddy Ruxpin main to the Teddy
Ruxpin toys with built-in audio phrases
camera one Wayne Campbell in camera two
Wayne Campbell is a reference to Wayne's
World Wayne's Campbell's joke with his
girlfriend camera one camera two
lighting by Tom Edison for Thomas Edison
little-known light bulb and Benner more
famous for inspiring that cowboy
scientist in Back to the Future Part
three security by Dalton the name of
Patrick Swayze's bouncer in Roadhouse
boom goes the dynamite ha did that mean
from all the way back in the mid-2000s
shoots it and boom goes the dynamite
grip chim chim that's a chimpanzee from
Speed Racer and eternal love for bug in
Parker is a reference to deadpool
commonly bugging peter parker in the
marvel comics deadpool loves Spidey
trailer ends with a two second shot of a
cybernetic hand reaching for weapons
parts now this probably belongs to cable
whose arm is cybernetic it was blocked
by Deadpool in that Good Housekeeping
poster finally as a bonus the
description of the YouTube for this
trailer is also a joke plot summary for
the movie it combines a bunch of dumb
tropes and references Mayberry is the
town of The Andy Griffith Show flux
capacitors obviously from that cowboy
scientist movie and some are saying
bovine attack could be a nod to the
flying cow in the earthworm jim video
game if so that is a
you've cut a rib eye sorry what cameo so
you want to see a Deadpool - I mean the
first step was such a huge head the
sequel deserves some love from the other
x-men
I know Hugh Jackman said Logan what's
his last Wolverine but come on he's got
a drop-by let me know your thoughts and
what made you laugh the most from this
teaser in the comments below or by
tweeting me at da boss you can also
follow the new rock stars at new rock
stars for updates on our channel like
and share this video and subscribe to
new rock stars for more obsessive
breakdown to the stuff you love and if
you want to be part of our team you can
contribute to us on patreon a huge huge
thank you to Kelly hopper who's been
such a generous help thank you so much
Kelly
for all of you thanks for watching bye
[Music]